MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, welcome to
Root Access, the show on GDL
about startups.
My name is Martin Omander,
and I work for
Google Developer Relations.
And today, I'm joined by none
other than Don Dodge--
fellow Googler, longtime
investor, and startup advocate.
Today, we'll handle
viewer questions.
And thank you for all your
comments coming in on YouTube,
by the way.
Keep them coming.
We love them.
Don, in our show about the
trends from the demo days,
recently for Y Combinator and
500 startups, you talked a
little about how investors
think.
You said something like, it
doesn't matter if you lose $3
million or $8 million.
And that sure got us a lot
of viewer comments.
One viewer commented that this
reasoning is very troubling
and like that of a
gambling addict.
Is that so?
DON DODGE: Well, yes, venture
capital investors
are gamblers by nature.
But let's put the question
in context.
The question was, if you invest
$100,000, does it
matter that the valuation is
5 million or 8 million?
And my answer to that was no,
it really doesn't matter.
Let me give you a
couple examples.
Let's say you invest $100,000
in a startup, and the
valuation is 5 million, and you
invest another $100,000 in
a startup that the valuation
is 8 million.
Both startups go out
of business.
You lose all of your money.
Does it matter that the first
startup you invested the
100,000 in was 5 million
valuation versus 8?
No, because you lost
all of your money,
so it doesn't matter.
Conversely, let's say you
invested 100,000 in a startup
at 5 million and 8 million,
and it goes to a billion
dollar valuation.
Does it matter that you invested
one at 5 million and
one 8 million when the exit
value was a billion?
On the margins, maybe,
but generally, no.
So it's counterintuitive, but
valuation is a very small
factor in your investment
decision.
So that was the point
of the question.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so owning
100% of zero or owning 50% of
zero, it's still zero.
DON DODGE: That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
Another viewer, [? Hejaneh ?]
[? Moolay ?]--
and I'm sorry if I butchered
your name, there-- commented
that investors are like
racing goers.
They go to the race.
They see all these race horses
that are the startups, and
they place their bets and lose
many of the bets and hope to
win once or twice.
Is that a good analogy?
DON DODGE: Yeah, I
think that works.
Venture capital investing
is very risky,
and it is like gambling.
And investors tend to
place multiple bets.
Rather than go all in on one
company, they'll place bets on
multiple companies, or in this
case, multiple horses.
And you know that you're going
to lose all of your money on
some of them, but the
expectation is that you'll
make 10 times your money or 100
times your money on one or
two of them and come out
very, very well.
So yes, venture capital
investors tend to take big
risks and maybe be
like gamblers.
As opposed to bankers, who when
you get a loan from a
bank, they're loaning against
assets, and they expect to
make 3% or 5% on their money.
It's a totally different mindset
of a venture capital
investor who expects to make
300% or 500% on their money.
So it's a different mindset, a
different risk profile, and
you need to take big risks in
order to make big money.
So it's just a very different
approach.
And gambling on race horses is
probably a good analogy.
MARTIN OMANDER: So what you're
saying is I shouldn't take my
retirement savings and put
it all into one startup.
DON DODGE: No, no, no, no.
And you shouldn't take your
venture money and put it all
into one startup either.
You should spread your risks.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, very
good, very good.
Another viewer, [? Andreas ?]
[? Felipe ?]
[? Diaz ?], commented on our
episode about how to get
funding, that we talked a lot
about how to get funding and
to what to put in a pitch, but
not how to get that meeting
with the investor.
That is a barrier, I think,
to many startups.
How do you get a meeting with
an investor, and how do
venture capitalists think
about who they talk to?
DON DODGE: Well, first of all,
go to where the money is.
So go to--
I was just a TechCruch Disrupt
yesterday for three days.
That's where hundreds and
hundreds of investors and
startups and press all get
together and present
new ideas on stage.
So go to conferences, go to
meetups, go to networking
events where investors and
entrepreneurs and startups
tend to congregate.
That's how you get access
to startups, to money.
Sending an email sometimes
works, but rarely.
But if you see the same person
in person at an event, you
develop an instant rapport and
can probably make more
progress that way.
It's like networking
with anything else.
If you're trying to hire some
engineers, the first thing you
do is network with other
engineers that you know,
because they have friends
who are engineers.
Same thing with investment.
When you're looking for angel
investors or VC investors, go
to an investor that
you know, because
they know other investors.
If you don't know any investors,
go to a startup
entrepreneur that you know
or someone who works at a
startup, because they have
investors, and they may
introduce you to their
investors.
And when you get that first
meeting with an investor, they
are likely to introduce you
to other investors.
So it's a social networking
kind of thing.
MARTIN OMANDER: So it sounds
like for hires, for
investment, for all kinds of
things, you need to be a good
networker to be a successful
startup.
DON DODGE: Absolutely.
Entrepreneurs need
to be extroverts.
And I've seen many, many
entrepreneurs who are
naturally introverts who, over
time, convert to extroverts.
Because you have to, to talk
to investors, and to hire
employees, and talk to
the press, and get
customers and users.
By nature, you're going to have
to go out there and talk
to them, so you develop into
more of an extrovert.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
there is hope.
It can be done.
DON DODGE: It can.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Thank you very much, Don.
And thank you all
for watching.
Please continue to leave your
comments and questions you'd
like us to bring up
in future episodes
in the YouTube comments.
And finally, I am also a
developer, and I've written
many apps myself on the
Google Cloud Platform.
I think it's a great platform.
And that we have a special offer
for Root Access viewers.
If you follow the instructions
on screen, you can get a
$2,000 credit so you can get
started on the platform.
Thank you very much, and
see you next time.